this video should not be necessary
because nobody should be celebrating
halloween in the first place in light of
covid if you celebrate halloween this
year you are
a biological terrorist but don't let
that distract from the fact that you're
also
probably a racist halloween is a holiday
rife with problematic potential many
people on halloween
including children especially children
in fact reveal themselves to be
clan members bigots nazi sympathizers
and
that's why i've decided to provide a
handy list of nine simple ways
to avoid being racist on halloween
it goes without saying that these rules
like all rules are intended for white
cisgendered heterosexuals only
everybody else can do literally whatever
they want
number one avoid costumes based on
characters
outside your race now this should be
obvious but it bears repeating
it is absolutely demeaning and
insensitive to pretend to be something
you're not
unless you're a man pretending to be a
woman in which case a parade should be
thrown in your honor but never mind that
now you might retort that the entire
damned point of halloween is to pretend
to be something you're not but
that argument only reveals your white
privilege look it's very simple
people of color are not here for your
amusement it's not acceptable to make a
mockery
of an entire race of people even if it's
not your intention to mock
now it's hard for you to understand the
pain caused by cultural caricatures
because you're white and
nobody ever makes ever a caricature of
white people
come on guys let's go apply for credit
cards come on just shut up
[Laughter]
i will fix it your mother is so old
that her breast milk is powdered you
breastfeed like this
when white people are alone they
give things to each other for free
a lot of you know from funny bastard
incidentally you know i just remember i
had a great discussion about this very
point
last saint paddy's day while i guzzled
green irish beer amid a crowd of drunken
hooligans dressed like leprechauns and
wearing shamrock glasses
i'm crazy paddy number two avoid
costumes
based on characters of the same race
what kind of message are you sending
when you dress
as a white person for halloween are
minority cultures not worthy of your
attention
would you be embarrassed to be seen in a
costume associated with a race that you
clearly find inferior
do you think that the only good
fictional characters are white
a white child dressed as a white
character is advocating
segregation he might as well just dress
up as jim crow or some other racist bird
the one thing more bigoted than mocking
a person of color
by dressing like them is excluding them
by not dressing like them
you should be ashamed number three avoid
costumes
made from material that originates from
historically oppressed regions
costumes made from cotton are definitely
ruled out for i would hope obvious
reasons costumes featuring
anything gold or sparkly must be ruled
out because
they may remind indigenous people of the
european explorers who came here to
rape their land and steal their gold
actually all fabrics
must be ruled out because east asia has
a prosperous textile trade
and has had one for many centuries and
don't even think about of course wearing
a jacket
if it's a little cold on halloween that
would be extremely offensive to eskimos
who are basically not white and i assume
invented jackets
also don't call them eskimos you racist
scumbag
number four and this is very important
avoid costumes
made from material that does not
originate from historically oppressed
regions
what are you trying to prove by dressing
your kid in that
plastic batman costume plastic was
invented by a white man
which is a point of pride for white
supremacists everywhere you hear them
chanting it in their marches
attended by millions we are the plastic
kings they shout
i think are you a white supremacist is
your kid
when you wear plastic you otherize and
exclude marginalized people who did not
have the opportunity to invent plastic
themselves
try to be a little sensitive for a
change you worthless drooling knuckle
dragging nazi
caveman number five avoid costumes that
marginalized people
would prefer you not wear now this one
isn't very hard at all
if a person from a marginalized group is
offended by your costume for any reason
whatsoever
my hair is not a costume it's not
something i just throw on to look cute i
mean
even though i do look cute that's not
the purpose of it
you must immediately tear it off and run
through the street naked
beating your chest and screaming maya
culpa maricopa made a maxima
the safest approach is to gather
together a focus group of your
500 closest minority friends and have
them vote on the appropriateness of your
costume
this is a process that i follow before i
get dressed every single day it only
takes about eight to ten hours usually
small price to pay in the name of
combating white supremacy
unless you don't care about combating
white supremacy
because you are a white supremacist
number six avoid costumes that you buy
from the store
think about it if you buy a costume from
a local retailer
that's one fewer costume that would be
available for the next
african-american latinx sudanese or
cambodian who walks through the door
in a sense by purchasing the costume you
are stealing it from a cambodian
worst of all store-bought costumes
costumes advertise your wealth and
privilege to disadvantage groups
who've long dreamed of going on a
shopping spree at party city
i i seriously can't believe that you
would even consider
buying a costume for your child you may
as well just cut to the chase and kick a
minority in the shins
disgusting disgusting well it's betting
season at my booking my bookie has
everything
you would expect from a sports book but
they also have political odds which are
a lot of fun you can bet on things like
the winner of the presidential election
uh even the day the loser will concede
the race it gets very specific
they've also got a lot of fun betting
opportunities for the upcoming
presidential debates
will joe biden call president trump a
racist will president trump
mention ted wheeler by name there are
many different uh things you could put
in there you can bet all this
and more at my bookie nothing makes an
event more exciting than putting some
money on it and with the nfl election
season in full swing
it's a great time to get in on the
action sometimes you have a gut feeling
about a match-up and sometimes you're
just
betting on your team because they're
your team that's my strategy for betting
which is why
i'm not very good at it regardless
whether you've been betting for years
or you're ready to to play for the first
time my bookie is your go-to
this season with the biggest online
selection of bets and props
they've made it simple to win and very
easy to withdraw your cash head over to
my bookie to create an account
just use the promo code walsh to claim
your 100 deposit match
all the way up to a thousand dollars
that means you put in 100 bucks
they give you 100 bucks it's a it's an
easy way to jumpstart your bankroll nfl
mba mlb everything else they've got it
all on tap and it's never too late to
get started on your winning season
right now only at my bookie number seven
avoid homemade costumes is there any
more obnoxious way to flaunt your
privilege than to wear a costume
you made yourself this is uh essentially
a big brown
sack they sewed some plastic fringe on
to
represent an entire group of indigenous
people
when i was a child i wanted to be a
knight for halloween so my mom
covered a cereal box in tin foil and put
it on my head
as i walked down the street thousands of
black and hispanic children looked at my
ritzy homemade outfit and wept
i learned then how dangerous halloween
can be the other problem of course is
that homemade clothing is customary in
many african and asian cultures
they have stitched their own garbs for
millennia
it's highly presumptuous for a white
person to partake in such an intimate
and long-standing minority tradition yet
again we have a case of
appropriation how could you even
consider doing something
that minorities do or don't do
number eight avoid costumes all costumes
are cultural appropriation
by definition if you'd studied history
you'd know that non-white cultures have
always worn costumes for their various
wonderful
festivals and so forth the wadaby tribe
in niger
joins together once a year for a ritual
celebration where many of the
participants wear elaborate face paint
and feathery attire
before you go out this halloween think
about how your costume will impact any
woodaby tribesmen
you may come across perhaps it's best to
forfeit costumes entirely number nine
avoid avoiding costumes
only a racist would forfeit costumes
entirely what
how what the forgo costumes on halloween
communicates
two things to marginalized populations a
you don't want to offend them because
you're afraid of them which perpetuates
the myth of the dangerous minority
b you don't want to partake in this fun
holiday with minorities because they
aren't equal to you
your decision to not wear a costume can
be extremely
dehumanizing to non-white people almost
as dehumanizing as your decision to wear
a costume
so these are the rules they will be on
my end
strictly enforced any white child who
comes knocking at my door will have to
follow the above protocols
also pass a short cultural sensitivity
quiz
and of course a coveted test and obtain
a waiver from their doctor
in order to receive a treat from me if
they fail well
they'll just have to hope that the guy
next door is handing out gluten-free
pita chips
mine are reserved for non-racists only
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated